hey guys Ryan Wright is here and Elissa
be crazy so today we're gonna check out
this trailer for a movie that I'm
actually really really intrigued to
watch I saw a photo still of this movie
it's called black mass stars Johnny Depp
why why I heard this um because this is
action drama this is a biographical
movie and there's a huge cast assembled
of great actors I'm excited to see this
because Johnny Depp's right I did a
video called what happened at Johnny
Depp's career he did that's right
and I'd pretty much Chronicle how great
he was and then worries that now
everyone's saying this could be the
return to Johnny Depp that we've been
waiting for I think he ever left I just
think he's so good what did you marinate
this steak because it's out of this
world you're killing me with Wow oh it's
a family secret
oh god you gotta tell me what's the
secret come on you could do it that is
one of the best goddamn steaks I ever
had in my life my solicitor what's the
fact what's the family secret recipe
this group has grown garlic over a soy
that's it yeah listen listen
I thought it was a family secret
it's your recipe no no you said to me
this is a family secret and you gave it
up to me boom just like that useful the
secret family recipe today maybe you
still lose some about me tomorrow I'm
saying he would just say you just saying
gets people sent boy just sayin
got me a nine-year stretch and Alcatraz
you understand so just say
could get you buried real quick look at
his face haha Wow that was a hell of a
cast yes whoo he's back okay what'd you
say thanks back up
he is so back this mic is on right okay
he is so back in the forum I've been
[ __ ] waiting for forever
he's it's a full-on dramatic performance
yeah last time he did a serious drama
like a real like biopic was actually
Public Enemies some people say
transcendence but it's Public Enemies
and Public Enemies it was a real-life
biopic gangster and I was actually a
little let down by that performance this
one though
talk about scary transformation it's
chilling is what it is scary
yeah he's genuinely terrifying in it I'm
listening to this guy and I'm like holy
crap I it's Johnny Depp but I'm so
scared of this dude I think that phony I
just would rather not have in my life
yeah I mean yeah the makeups great the
eye contact should hurt the teeth work
is great all the design of him is great
I'm not familiar with who this real-life
gangster is nobody loved to learn more
absurd a person's history this looks
like such a great crime drama I love how
the whole trailer was overlapped by this
one monologue he was giving I know but
the whole pattern met monologue
it was a great monologue but you guys
remember that old commercial meet it's
what's for dinner like that was just
going through my head the whole time I'm
like what is this that's the point then
I got to the point and it just it hit
really hard do you know things hitting
hard aren't you wow-wow in the beginning
it's not so serious like there's an
underlying serious tome but that's not
what you take it as at first and it just
gets really serious
is really fast okay so what we're seeing
in this is not so much the actual story
they're really communicating a tone and
this criminal underworld of this guy
runs right first off Johnny Depp there's
so much talk about him just this trailer
alone his performance is that of a
three-dimensional personality he's
finally not playing mr. whacko guy again
he's doing a real person there's a
personality in him there's menace in
this guy there's trauma in this dude you
know like you feel like a guy who's
disturbed and is run by like some type
of evil in him like you could feel all
that just in this two minutes that we
got he has the intimidating factor in
crime movies that's what a lot of ones
that fall flat black is the intimidation
factor and he owns it he's been making a
lot of movies lately that seem targeted
for like family audiences it's cool to
see him do an r-rated flick that is
targeted for like adult crime world
audiences and what a great cast the guy
who he's talking to at the dinner scene
I remember he was in the last season of
The Walking Dead that just aired and he
was really good in it but you got a
whole [ __ ] cast assemble in this I
know I got joel edgerton who is an
amazing actor Benedict Cumberbatch I
know I found there's like a flashers
yeah is that it damn crazy guy and you
got Kevin Bacon as well and the girl
from Fifty Shades Dakota Johnson's in
this so you got this whole cast that is
on board for this awesome crime drama
yeah I saw Adam Scott was in this - I
made a top 10 most anticipated list I
got a knock one of those off and put
this on here really I look so [ __ ]
good and this is I think one of those
things where because it's based on a
true story and it looks so well done
even people who aren't a fan of crime or
suspense would enjoy it I really hope
the performances as good as the trailer
man because that that is something else
that is something else anyway guys
thanks so much for mentioning I was out
seriously if you're new the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects Elissa
be crazy has a channel - Elissa be crazy
a lot of fun stuff on there challenges
stories and vlogs
but it's just fun stuff and you can
follow us both on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
where Alyssa is having competition with
another girl in the channel name Ariana
that who has the biggest breast size I
mean I don't really even think it's a
competition so are you singing you're
bigger well I'm not just gonna take out
my shrimp and be like okay why don't you
want to win they've known me longer
don't you want to much for bacon ouch
for me you guys have known me for like a
year I'd be disappointed if you didn't
vote for me we got a challenge going the
boob challenge